الاول من يوليو 2013 انضمت كرواتيا
للاتحاد الاوروبي لكن بدا من الاول من
يناير 2023 سترفع للمره الاولى الحواجز
على الحدود البريه والبحريه والسكك
الحديديه الداخليه بينها وبين دول منطقه
شنغن على ان ترفع الحواجز الجويه الداخليه
في ال 26 من مارس المقبل وذلك وفق بيان
الحكومه الكرواتيه التحول يشمل ايضا
التخلي عن العمله الكرواتيه المحليه كونا
لصالح اليوم وسيجر التبادل بين العمتين في
البنوك الكرواتيه مجانا حتى نهايه العام
موقعه اتفاقيه شنغن عام 1985 وبدا سريانها
عام
1995 تضم منطقه 26 بلدا بينها اربع دول من
خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي يتعين اجماعها
بالكامل على انضمام اي دوله جديده ويعيش
في هذه المنطقه نحو اربع مئه مليون شخص
ويصل طول حدود المنطقه الخارجيه 50,000
كلم ويتوقع ان يسهم انضمام كرواتيا الى
فضائل شنجن واليورو في تحسين اقتصاد
البلاد وان يزيد قدرتها التنفسيه بفضل
تداول المجانيه والاسرع والارخص للسلع
والخدمات بين الدول الاعضاء كما سيفر
الدعم لقطاعها السياحي الذي يمثل 20% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
[موسيقى]